[Music]
on September 22nd
time for music We heard you this is
gonna be fun
[Music]
and clear
please make Expendables for rated R
there better be violence and lots of it
I want all the blood and guts [__] it
first things first holy [__]
my mind is full of these brutal
fantasies fantasies
[Music]
I will now become a headless reality
it's a great idea
well I ain't playing no more
you almost [__] kill me you're
welcome
now that's what I'm talking about
good to be back
[Music]
enjoy the show
s definitely
rated R
in theaters September 22nd
thank you
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
come with you oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
nothing can get enough playing the
dangerous
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
what's up the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
don't shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be World War III
to choose this life over friends
over family
It's Time to Get Loud
next slide baby
[Music]
I'm gonna win big
ship of imitation distance
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got oh
it's way bigger than that
foreign
[Music]